لقد تعلمت عن الصحافة التليفزيونية التي
أشاهدك في البلقان،
وكان ذلك بمثابة نافذتي على هذه الأشياء
، واعتقدت أن هذا أمر طبيعي تمامًا،
ولم يكن أمرًا استثنائيًا ولكن الأربعين
عامًا التي برزت لك جيدًا،
هذا هو الشيء الذي حدث قبل 40 عامًا  لقد كنت
مساعدًا مكتبيًا، لذا انضممت إلى شبكة CNN بعد تخرجي
من الكلية عمليًا وذهبت
إلى هناك،
لكنني كنت أعلم حقًا أن هذا هو
نوع التقارير التي أردت القيام بها، وذهبت
في مهمة لأكون
مراسلًا أجنبيًا، كما تعلمون، اذهب إلى
أزمات العالم ومحاولة شرحها للناس
ومحاولة جعلها ذات صلة بالشعب
الأمريكي وبقية
جمهورنا العالمي ومن ناحية فهي
مغامرة ضخمة ومن ناحية أخرى
مسؤولية ضخمة نظرًا لمنصة CNN الضخمة
والمهمة ومدى انتشارها  لكنني
أشعر أن هذا مبتذل
ولكن عليك حقًا تسليط
الضوء في الأماكن التي لا يذهب إليها الكثيرون. لقد
كانت إيران دائمًا منبوذة أنا نصف
إيراني كما تعلمون منذ أن بدأت
العمل لقد كنت نوعًا ما  اضطررت إلى التوفيق بين
هذا الموقف والتعامل معه
والتعاطف مع أولئك الذين
وقعوا ضحايا لذلك النظام
بما في ذلك الأمريكيين المحتجزين ظلما،
ولذا عندما أتيحت لي الفرصة على سبيل
المثال لإجراء مقابلة مع سي آر ماجنامازي،
تعلم أنني تخطيت الأمر ولم أكن أعرف  ما هي
العواقب بالنسبة له التي كانت
أكبر مخاوفي ما هي
العواقب بالنسبة له لم
يفعل أحد ذلك من قبل من قبل، كان يتمتع
بامتيازات ثابتة بحكم وجوده هناك
لمدة ثماني سنوات ونصف كان قد انتقل
منها أه كما تعلم
قسوة الحبس الانفرادي إلى حد أقل قسوة
ولكن مع زملائي الأمريكيين الآخرين
أم لكن كما تقول البلقان التي
علمتني ما يعنيه قول
الحقيقة أنه في البلقان عندما كان هناك
معتدٍ واضح النظام الصربي
لسلوبودان ميلوسيفيتش  ضحية واضحة،
الدولة البوسنية التي أعلنت
استقلالها للتو أرادت أن تكون ديمقراطية
مؤيدة للغرب، إنها الحرب الأولى في
أوروبا منذ الحرب العالمية الثانية وليست أوكرانيا
وروسيا هي التي كانت كذلك وكانت هناك
جرائم حرب وتعلمت هناك أن أكون
صادقًا وليس محايدًا.